petit revenu quand influencer les gars
de la peau à herisau
passé la journée en deux pancartes qui
disent à ralentir par arrow
fille spirituelle d'yvon deschamps
pierre légaré s'est tout de suite
démarquer des autres humoristes par ses
jeux de mots et son humour réfléchi
quand on est sûr qu'à la fin marchera
pas enfin de croître c'est pour ça que
nos bulletins de vote match demain
personne va falloir remplacer
parce que au même titre qu'ils vont
d'échec est remplaçable piet légal est
un monument compromis entre jamais
s'approcher incident du monde jamais
c'est alors je trouve qu'on pose on a
des pourquoi continuer je pense je
continue d'avoir tous ces nombreux
questionnements existentiels le pousse à
s'inscrire en psychologie à l'université
mais l'appel de l'humour est trop fort
et rapidement il tisse des liens
d'amitié psychologue cévennes formation
psychologue si je pense que c'est est un
titre qui allait bien parce
qu'effectivement il est à l'écouté dès
qu'on avait besoin d'un conseil on
pouvait l'apli qui étaient là pour pour
répondre
andré monnard aussi aller choquette et
bien d'autres connaîtront le succès
grâce à ses textes à 40 ans pierre
légaré décide de monter sur scène pierre
toujours été reconnu comme quelqu'un
avec des textes intelligents des
réflexions pertinentes
et quelqu'un qui avait une vision du
monde particulière ce qui m'a fait
monter sur une scène était surtout de
l'insatisfaction pendant les années 90
il présentera quatre spectacles pour
lesquels il obtiendra deux félix et
trois oliviers il rédigera plusieurs
recueils d'humour son inspiration il la
puise est à même son quotidien mission
qui a changé ma vie bien sûr comme toute
autre personne qui sont intenses qui
questionne qui qu'il faut que nous
avançons dans notre cheminement
jusqu'aux gens d'affaires la page
couverture et d'une quinzaine d'années
un concert le force à se retirer de la
vie publique mais pierre légaré demeure
une référence
sa voix nous manque sur l'actualité la
polarisation convient la radicalisation
les réseaux sociaux et sur certaines ch
et dormiront poche je pense qu'il ya
vraiment à ce que la lumière des
témoignages qu'on soit aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il ya un énorme potentiel
le les rentes publiques et accessibles
puis à l'égaré était le maître des
traits d'esprit son art demeure bien
présent dans le coeur des amateurs
d'humour ici louis philippe ouimet radio
canada montréal